my guest tonight started numerous films
including factory girl
american sniper and american woman now
you can see her in the new movie
wander darkly which is terrific it's
available
on demand please welcome the beautiful
and talented sienna
miller all the way from london hello
sienna hello
conan how are you i'm doing very well
now you look
stunning uh and and you're just the
whole
this looks like a christmas card right
now you're beautiful and your background
is beautiful yeah i'm almost matching
your background which is extremely
festive as well i need some colored
lights
you've inspired me well you seem to be
in a lovely home
i'm in an abandoned theater in hollywood
that's overrun with rats so
you talk about your crew that way
uh now you look you look very uh like
you're in the christmas spirit
are you excited about christmas right
now um as much as one can be excited
about anything this year
yes yeah yes christmas
tell me because i know that was not
convincing you know
and and you're an actress and you
couldn't pull that off for 2020
which is
yeah did i'm curious
do you i've always thought that the
perfect christmas would be
in london because it it seems it's it's
charles dickens
it's the perfect place to celebrate
christmas is it what are the traditions
what will you be doing on christmas day
that feels very british to you
i can outdo your london with my 16th
century thatched cottage
in the dickensian town of west wickham
i've just told the world my address not
that anyone cares
and it's like
it's a hobbit house it sort of looks
like something out of middle earth and
i'll sit by the fire and i will drink
red wine and i will be in pajamas and i
will eat
and eat that sounds fantastic i have to
say that sounds absolutely
lovely um and i can't believe you live
in a you live in a thatched
cottage that just makes me so
happy it sounds like a fairy tale it
actually
is it really is it's a fairy tale what
are the kind of
you know i've always heard that in
europe every country has
uh their own little traditions i don't
know what you do
are there any traditions that you have
because in america we just open the
presents
and then we insult each other what do
you do in uh
in london or or growing up you're there
certain games you play
or ways to pass the time in england we
opened the booze
before the presents that also leads to
catastrophic fights
but we do sit around the kitchen table
and we play a game called name in a hat
have you ever played that game no you
put
everybody puts like five famous names of
famous people dead or alive into a hat
folded up and you're on two teams and
you pull an extra i've got a call
it's not going it's okay that's okay
pull a name out of the hat and i have to
describe who the name is without saying
the name
and as the rounds go on you just get one
word so by the time you've played three
rounds you could say walking stick and
they go winston churchill because
you've done walking stick cigar whatever
right so the first round you'd say
walking stick cigar
yeah yeah world war ii um
if you got my name what would you say if
you got conan
funny nice thank you
thank you attractive charming
good luck guess what
yeah sienna no one would get it if you
said that
[Laughter]
you need to say uh you need to say thin
lips
uh aging badly and people will go conan
and then you yeah that's the way to do
it
um you know sienna i've i've i met you a
long
it's a long time ago i think i was one
of your first talk show appearances
uh way back in the day and you've always
been
um very stylish and sort of blazing a
trail i i
in my opinion in style you always look
so fantastic
some people say that you're responsible
for the ugg craze
because you were one of the first people
famous people to wear uggs
out and around with anything once i
discovered that there was a shoe that
felt like a slipper that you could wear
on the street there was no turning back
because i i actually love comfort i'm
gonna i'm gonna show you a secret this
is very elegant on the top but look
it's a tracksuit i like it
so but i'm curious you i think you were
i remembered
i remembered seeing a picture of you
looking very beautiful and you're
wearing
a short i think a short skirt if i
remember correctly and
uggs with the short skirt and it worked
but it felt like
you you just knew it would work when if
you just if someone described that to me
i would say no that's not going to work
but it worked it was beautiful
thanks i don't know how to respond to
that other than thank you
i i think i did just wear them with
everything to the point where they'd
slightly kind of collapsed inwards
and i've probably got my back because
i've aged but still i wear them
well my only question is have you been
compensated
by the ugg people because that's a very
uh powerful company they make a lot of
money i'm hoping
that they have cut you in for a piece of
the ugg empire because you deserve it
ugh pie they have not they send me free
boots
occasionally but no there is no slice of
that pie so i think we should start the
make a sienna ambassador ugg campaign
but yeah sienna if you'd like
i'm very powerful in show business uh in
america
and um well parts of america
um a very small part of america i'm very
powerful
if you'd like i'll get involved and i
will secure you
a piece of the ugg empire okay yes thank
you
um you know one thing you and i both
have in common is we both
have famously beautiful hair
and um but mine has become
very unkempt and ragged during
the quarantine yours looks beautiful and
i understand that you're
quite good at taking care of your own
hair that you have uh
you know your talented hair stylist is
that true i am
a closet hairdresser that sounds wrong
but you know what i mean
and throughout lockdown i put the
designated hair
cutter not that that's the right phrase
either
but i had to use kitchen scissors
because we didn't have proper scissors
but i gave
some pretty epic cuts to people and i've
always cut my own fringe and
bangs i should say i could do a bit of
that with a scissor
if i i could do yeah that thing when
they
twist it around and they go which they
do
i've when i've grown my hair very long
um they do that sometimes to give it a
little twist at the bottom give it a
little like
lightness on the ends yeah the um
you know i think it's a it takes a lot
of
trust to let someone i mean i don't even
trust professionals to get near my hair
but i would trust you you know i i i
think
i i would trust you i feel like i know
you
um and i would let you cut my hair
someday
if that were something you were
interested in so how about when this
whole
[ __ ] show ends um i could come and give
you a cut
are you referring to my show or the
court or the quarantine epidemic
the world and the coveted restrictions
when it's over live on air because
you've now pledged that you would let me
so i'm gonna hold you to it
yeah i will i will fly to london
uh to see you because i think any man
would
i will fly to london to see you and uh
you will cut my hair we'll shoot it for
the show
and then um and then i'll sue you and
we'll both be suing each other for a
while
and we'll be in the courts we could get
them to fly us to an exotic location
yes yes
haircut it's going to be a straight down
a lockdown special
i love that and have a reality show
and screw ugh because we'll be making so
much money that way
yeah and it's gonna be great i you know
it will be it'll be a version of love
island only
just where you where you cut my hair
obviously there's absolutely no sexual
tension
i mean there is on my part but not on
your part and it's
it's a version of love island that isn't
quite as saucy as
love island that's what we'll do it'll
be quite lady macbeth i'll creep up with
scissors
all the time of the
and it's just on an island and one pair
of says is what will happen
and then a lot of me and the
confessional with
ragged looking hair saying she did it
again i was sleeping
sienna came in she chunk she cut off a
chunk on this side
um i want to talk to you about wander
darkly
i had the chance to uh talk to diego
luna about the film
i got to see the film and your
performance
is so wrenching this is
i i can't imagine what you went through
to
have to play this part because it is
such a demanding role
it is such an incredibly demanding role
it's it
i don't want to try and sum up the movie
but it's a very intense story about a
couple and they go through
trauma and then it's trying to figure
out which reality is the correct reality
and it's beautifully done and
beautifully acted but
i felt i don't know how you survived
every day of
filming that movie because it felt like
you had to be wrung out
at the end of every day yes that might
be the understatement of the year it was
so tiring it was just it was but there's
really weirdly catharsis in that kind of
work
i don't know it's strange but yes it was
hard it was hard and it was confusing
and disorienting and
all of those things but we didn't know
that we were we had no
idea how it was going to come together
and i think they did a really beautiful
job with all the effects and
you know it's surreal i think you summed
it up very well as a story because it's
very hard for me to ever describe what
it's about but
with sort of a life-affirming loving
feeling at the end
even if you've been through something
yeah you you bet you definitely
uh you you go through a lot you watch
this couple go through a lot
but i was talking to diego and diego uh
obviously gives a
a a terrific performance but i felt your
character had to
you just had to really put it all out
there in a way that
i i can't not being an actor i can't
even imagine
what that's like but um it's a it's a
really terrific performance
thank you conan i think i've explored
grief now at this point
i don't know that i've got any more to
show from that perspective i think i'm
ready for some tap dancing
reality haircutting
i would imagine we have a clip we're
going to show now from wander darkly
uh which in which i think it's actually
a very good clip to show in this moment
because
it encapsulates the extremes
that your character is driven to in this
film and again uh
this just gives you a taste of some of
the intensity of the movie
and it's just like i say the tip of the
iceberg yeah
so let's show this clip uh right now
from wonder darkly
[Applause]
you weren't there with ellie where do
you go
what happens to you you just you get
scared and then what you just
you disappear you concussed
that's it yeah
i'm dead if i can step into traffic now
it wouldn't matter hey
hey
[Applause]
it's okay what is this like purgatory
what's happening to me just hold on to
me
well are you able to film now in
london are you able to work now during
the pandemic i'm
shooting which is astounding and we have
not shut down and i've been at it from
the beginning of november and it's
surreal i mean everybody's in masks and
goggles and like i don't know what
anybody looks like and i
you know like to kind of hug people
that's not happening
but we are managing to make this show
which is
which is great tiring this is uh
and i'm just we are doing the same thing
which is we're
we have been making shows wearing masks
getting tested
and um we're starting to get used to it
even though it's been months and months
but uh really looking forward to this
being over
me too me too although i've had many
people tell me
they uh even when this is over they
don't want me to hug them
so yeah apparently that was
probably that was an issue with me
um well it's it's just delightful to
talk to you it really is
and uh i want to make sure i mention
because it's a terrific film wander
darkly
is now on demand on apple tv prime video
or wherever
you get your movies and uh
i hope you have a lovely holiday in your
thatched hut
thank you getting quietly uh imbibing
an appropriate amount of liquor and i
look forward to seeing you
sometime when covet is over when you and
i will be on a secluded island and you
will cut my hair
for a british reality show done done
all right you're gonna regret saying
that
santa miller thank you very much thank
you conan